und jetzt wartet einfach ab dass die
frau die die frauen karte nicht ziehen
wollte bei der kandidatenfrage und die
nur deshalb kandidatin geworden ist weil
sie die frauen karte gezogen wird dass
die jetzt dokumentieren müssen
nachweisen muss dass sie wirklich und
zwei für die bessere es ihnen gegenüber
was ich nicht glaube kommt das rückspiel
jetzt kommt das rückspiel von robert
habeck nein er ist diszipliniert genug
zu wissen dass öffentliche erklärungen
oder piesacken in die richtung von
werbung der parteien nicht nützen ihm
vor allen dingen auch nicht nützen aber
er lässt sie sozusagen langen
erfahrungen sowie sagen sie uns am ende
noch denken sie dass die grünen daraus
wieder zurückkommen können in den
wahlkampf oder war das jetzt schon das
vorzeitige ende eines erfolgreichen
wahlkampf
naja man kann jedenfalls nicht mehr mit
der kunstfigur in der werbung arbeiten
sie sollte uns da präsentiert werden ich
kenne ja ein teil der kampagne als
merkel für ärmel also junge merkel die
auch die welt retten will die sehr genau
weiß was sie tut die alle studiert und
soweit diese diese diese kunstfigur kann
nicht mehr präsentiert wenn das heißt
die grünen sind ein teil ihrer kampagne
umstellen
es ist zu spät einen neuen
kanzlerkandidaten ausgerufen und die
distanz zwischen union und grünen
mittlerweile so groß dass auch niemand
ernsthaft glaubt dass die grünen jemals
den kanzlerkandidaten kann es da jetzt
bei der wahl stellen werden